ahora que ya sabemos cómo dibujar una
estructura de enlace línea vamos a
aplicar esta habilidad que ya tenemos
para dibujar algunos isómeros
estructurales y tú te estarás
preguntando qué son los isómeros verdad
pero bueno esencialmente eso significa
digamos mismo lo mismo y meros pero
significa partes ok entonces isómeros
podrían ser las moléculas que están
hechas de las mismas partes es cuando
nos referimos realmente al mismo número
de átomos así que por ejemplo si yo
tengo el c5 h 12 que esencialmente es el
penta no entonces podría dibujar al
menos al menos dos estructuras de puntos
distintas que vamos a que van a tener la
misma fórmula molecular y entonces
diríamos que esas dos estructuras son
isómeros el uno del otro y esas dos
estructuras podrían diferir a lo mejor
en cómo se están conectando estos átomos
ok o si difieren en términos de su
estructura que es justamente por lo cual
se les conoce como isómeros
estructurales
el otro término que también se utiliza
es el de y son de los constitucionales
así que algunos constitucionales así que
algunas veces
quizás en algunos libros de texto
todavía hoy probablemente los llamarían
y son menos constitucionales yo prefiero
el viejo término de isómeros estructural
porque al menos para mí me dice un
poquito más acerca de qué tipo de
isómeros o de bueno qué tipo de arreglos
de diferencias hay entre estas moléculas
así que vamos a ver qué es lo que
podemos hacer aquí tenemos 5 carbonos
que vamos a poner justo en una línea
aunque ya en una estructura de línea
vamos a poner ahí 5 carbonos muy bien
ahí como como lo hicimos en el en los
vídeos anteriores ahora sí si queremos
verificar realmente la fórmula vamos por
ejemplo a extenderlo un poco más tenemos
aquí nuestros 5 carbonos y vamos a ver
cuántos hidrógenos tenemos entonces aquí
sólo tenemos un enlace por lo tanto le
corresponden 3 aquí hay dos enlaces así
que sólo le faltan dos hidrógenos
nuevamente aquí dos aquí también 2 y
aquí tiene tres posibles hidrógenos de
hecho tiene exactamente tres hidrógenos
entonces
5 carbonos y tenemos 3 5 7 9 12
hidrógenos muy bien entonces este es una
estructura posible con esta fórmula
molecular veamos ahora si podemos hacer
otra estructura por ejemplo qué tal si
quitamos este carbono de al final
ponemos 1 2 3 4 y tenemos que acomodar
el otro carbono en algún lado por
ejemplo aquí muy bien vamos a ver cómo
se vería esto tenemos este carbón unido
a este carbón a este otro ya este otro y
quedamos que el otro carbono queda acá
arriba muy bien entonces vamos a ver si
éste también tiene los 12 hidrógenos que
necesita esta forma está bueno esta
molécula como fórmula o más bien que nos
indica esta fórmula molecular entonces
aquí tenemos espacio para tres
hidrógenos aquí tenemos tres enlaces así
que sólo le corresponde un hidrógeno
verdad aquí tenemos dos así que le
corresponden otros dos aquí tenemos solo
uno así que le corresponden tres
hidrógenos y aquí tenemos solo un enlace
por lo que le corresponden
tres hidrógenos entonces si contamos
tenemos 3 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 así que
tienen exactamente la misma fórmula
molecular verdad tienen 5 carbonos 12
hidrógenos entonces decimos que son
isómeros estructurales el uno del otro
vamos a dibujar ahora otra molécula y
veamos si es un isómero estructural de
estos dos dos sujetos ok entonces y de
hecho lo que hicimos fue tomar este
último carbono y ponerlo acomodarlo en
esta parte de acá verdad y lo hicimos de
forma arbitraria así que veamos qué
pasaría si tomamos otro o si tomamos ese
mismo carbón y lo acomodamos por ejemplo
en esta o en este otro posible es decir
que para que tal si en vez de ponerlo
donde lo pusimos en el caso anterior
ahora se encuentra aquí en principio tú
podrías decir ah mira es otra otro
isómero estructural verdad pero en
realidad son la misma molécula estas son
las mismas moléculas simplemente la de
abajo
es ver como si la de arriba las notarás
y así es como se obtienen que son las
mismas moléculas simplemente lo rotamos
guardarlos lo volteamos así que son no
no son isómeros estructura estructurales
perdón son exactamente la misma molécula
así que vamos a dibujar otro digamos
tenemos mi rama como en el ejemplo
anterior digamos ahora sólo vamos a
tomarnos tres vamos a tomarnos tres
carbonos muy bien y ahora acomodamos
aquí un carbono y aquí otro carbono
entonces si te das cuenta tenemos 5
carbonos entonces cómo se vería esto
algo así
algo así muy bien y ahora nuevamente
necesitamos ver cuántos hidrógenos
tenemos entonces si nos damos cuenta en
cada uno de estos caben tres hidrógenos
pueden se tienen tres hidrógenos en cada
uno de estos carbonos mientras que en el
carbono central ya tenemos cuatro
enlaces así que a éste no le corresponde
ni un solo hidrógeno entonces tenemos 5
carbonos y tenemos 3 hidrógenos en cada
uno de estos 4 carbonos exteriores
entonces tenemos 12 verdad tenemos 12 y
nuevamente tenemos un isómero
estructural de este c 5 h 12 muy bien
que al inicio le llamamos venta no este
sería un 2 metil propano y así podríamos
darle los distintos nombres que ya
veremos después cómo hacerlo lo
importante es que todos estos son
hidrocarburos o alcanos y que como ya
les mencioné vamos a meternos en la
nomenclatura de arcanos en vídeos
futuros ahora vamos a hacer otro ejemplo
vamos a tomarnos
otro ejemplo vamos a hacer ahora el c3 h
8 o muy bien tenemos 3 carbonos 8
hidrógenos y un oxígeno ok entonces de
hecho ya en vídeos anteriores
hicimos este ejemplo y de hecho lo
hicimos de esta forma poníamos estos 3
carbonos y aquí poníamos nuestro o h
verdad aquí poníamos el h entonces solo
voy a enumerar estos los carbonos como 1
2 y 3 entonces vamos a desarrollarlo
para ver que en efecto cumple esta
fórmula entonces tenemos nuestros 3
carbonos y unidos a nuestro h el carbono
central está unido al h muy bien
entonces vamos a contar hidrógenos a
este le caben 3 hidrógenos mientras que
a este central sólo 1 verdad a este de
acá le caben tres
y entonces recordemos que aquí tenemos
un hidrógeno y contamos tenemos 3 4 5 6
7 8 hidrógenos y 11
oxígeno entonces tenemos una estructura
de lewis para esta molécula ahora qué
tal bueno nosotros queremos encontrar y
son menos estructurales que tal que éste
o bache se encuentra en algún otro lugar
que no está en el centro digamos que a
lo mejor está pegado en nuestro primer
carbono
entonces aquí tendríamos el 1 2 y 3 y
vamos a ver que en efecto son y son
menos estructurales aquí tenemos nuestro
h unido a un carbono a otro y a otro
ahora vamos a contar hidrógenos aquí le
caben dos hidrógenos acá también dos
hidrógenos y aquí tres hidrógenos
cuántos hidrógenos tenemos tenemos aquí
tres cuatro cinco seis siete y ocho y
tenemos un único oxígeno así que otra
vez son y soneros el detalle es que este
de acá arriba se llama 2 propanol y el
de aquí se llama 1 propanol justamente
por el lugar en donde se está pegando
nuestro o h a ver por ejemplo qué
pasaría si él o h no estuviera en el 1
ni en el 2 sino en el 3 es decir que
tuviéramos algo así y entonces nos
preguntamos con isómeros y la respuesta
por supuesto es que no
estas dos son exactamente las mismas
moléculas verdad simplemente estamos
volteando las muy bien entonces son
exactamente la misma molécula pero por
ejemplo si quisiéramos dibujar algún
otro digamos este que es lo que
podríamos hacer realmente ya no podemos
ramificar a estos carbonos verdad como
lo hicimos en el ejemplo anterior no
podemos tener más ramificaciones de
carbonos o de ninguna otra cosa no no
tenemos suficientes carbonos para eso
así que lo único que podríamos intentar
hacer para dibujar otro isómero
estructural podría ser romper la cadena
de carbonos y meter un oxígeno en medio
entonces vamos a ver qué pasaría si
hacemos esa lo mejor que puede ser una
locura verdad a ver tenemos esta cadena
pero en vez de pegarse aquí a un carbono
que en realidad va a ser un oxígeno y
después se pega a un carbono entonces
vamos a ver cómo se podría dibujar esto
entonces tenemos nuestro carbono aquí
otro carbono acá se pega al oxígeno y d
tenemos un enlace con un carbono y el
resto tendrían que ser hidrógenos verdad
aquí por supuesto completamos el octeto
del oxígeno y vamos a ver tenemos aquí
tres hidrógenos aquí vamos a tener solo
dos aquí bueno es el oxígeno y aquí
vamos a tener tres entonces si hacemos
el conteo tenemos 123 carbonos mientras
que de hidrógenos tenemos 358 hidrógenos
y un oxígeno entonces tenemos otra vez
un isómero estructural de esto bueno que
es un isómero estructural de estos dos
anteriores de estos dos ejemplos
anteriores verdad por ejemplo también a
lo mejor uno podría ocurrírsele que el
oxígeno estuviera aquí pero es el mismo
caso verdad son la misma molécula
simplemente están un poco invertidos el
único detalle es que difieren mucho en
lo que le llamamos los grupos
funcionales verdad
si te fijas muy bien ya no podemos hacer
ninguna otra ramificación no podemos
meter el oxígeno en algún otro lado
hemos ya ha agotado todas las
posibilidades así que son nuestros tres
y son menos estructurales y te darás
cuenta que realmente son muy distintos
el uno del otro y justamente por lo que
les comentaba el primero de ellos el
primero de ellos era el dos propanol y
el segundo era el 1 propanol y este
último este último de aquí que pintamos
y se le conoce como el steel metil éter
así que estos son grupos funcionales muy
distintos y éste
los dos primeros en realidad son
alcoholes son del grupo funcional de los
alcoholes mientras que este último y
somero estructural en realidad es es un
éter así que tenemos que aprender sobre
los grupos funcionales distintos que
existen y eso lo vamos a trabajar en el
próximo vídeo hay muchos pero muchísimos
grupos funcionales que tenemos que
aprender y es extremadamente importante
entender entenderlos por el resto del
curso